the person tasked with fixing president
biden's border crisis is in france today
vice president kamala harris rolling
through paris with this 20-car motorcade
she's there to patch up the rocky
relationship with our oldest ally after
president biden left france in the dark
on a submarine deal she'll also discuss
the migrant crisis but not the one on
our southern border no she's apparently
more focused on the immigration crisis
in europe this morning the vice
president toured a coveted 19 lab in
paris this is her third foreign trip and
comes as her approval numbers take a big
nosedive
so pete let me get this straight our
borders are uh is in europe to discuss
not our border problem but europe's
but to be fair uh the border problem
that they have in europe was created by
the libyan intervention underneath obama
and biden in 2011. so when they broke
that uh whole situation migrants flooded
into europe and because europe has long
since not defended its sporters and
doesn't believe in itself uh it has it's
been effectively defenseless but you
wonder why her approval rating is at 28
i can handle a bad leader just don't
give me somebody who refuses to leave
elite at all and so she won't even go to
the border recognize the issues talk
about them um because she has no
solution for them so this will she's i
think they're trying to shore up her
foreign policy creds because maybe she
still lives under the fantasy that she
can run for president at some point but
she might want to look at like doing
some things because that usually is what
helps your numbers right not a pr
campaign which she's been on for a while
emily we heard from a senior
administration official what we can
expect to hear from kamala harris they
say she's going to express a deep
concern for human rights in the
situation of migrants and refugees and
reinforce the imperative of protecting
vulnerable people including those uh
fleeing conflict how she's living up to
that here in the united states it's all
talking to action you guys since day one
it has been all talk all promises and no
action and that has been the hallmark of
her public service uh career for decades
frankly those of us who lived in san
francisco and california under her watch
know that exactly well and to pete's
point about being in europe you know
ironically across the southern border
obviously border patrol has reported
migrants illegal migrants coming from
over 120 countries so she should know
then doing her homework to europe that's
it's absolutely impacting our southern
border so where was she to the point to
that hollow statement where was she when
in august we had record-breaking numbers
of unaccompanied migrant children 15
000. where was she
with the 1.66 million arrests just
through september alone this year on
their southern border that's more than
three times her for some reason the
press likes to think of oakland as her
hometown even though it's not that's
three times that population where was
she on the 33 recorded instances of
sexual abuse in one month alone by the
department of health and human services
the staggering covid transmission rates
among migrants over the border that
eclipses the rate that shut down our
public school system the list goes on
but the reality is the southern border
is absolutely crippling our economy down
there and it's stressing so many towns
up through and including all 50 states
that are crippled by opioid and fentanyl
addiction and overdoses and yet she is
seen gallivanting around to pete's point
if it's shoring up foreign policy or her
foreign policy chops then i would like
to demand another meeting between her
and president obador because we need
some type of semblance of leadership for
our southern border and it's not her and
where was she on illegal immigrant
children on suicide watch list and her
and biden's emergency intake facilities
she's been woefully absent on a lot as
you point out maybe that's why she has a
stunningly low 27.8 approval rating you
know i've said it before i thought it'd
be hard to find someone more unlikable
than hillary clinton but then we get
this kind of
comment from our vice president at nasa
can you measure
trees because part of that data that
you're referring to
and it's an ej it's environmental
justice but you can also track
by race
there are averages in terms of the
number of trees in the neighborhood
where people live
um
it's it's profound and shocking
so the environmental justice of trees i
mean she's just focusing on the wrong
things
look what she's focusing on is something
that must be politically expedient to
this administration we may not know how
but that tends to be a trend line here
and i think that that's something that
when reporters gather at the white house
press briefing they can ask about you
know why would you choose this over more
pertinent energy issues and inflation
and stuff at home we're not you know
looking at it and saying these things
aren't important we're just wondering
why not focus on the things that are
urgent and and critical to the success
of the american people and that would be
a fair question i i have two things i
wonder about with kamala harris one is
what is it in her pedigree on her resume
that says
crisis in europe send her yeah right
what is it
i mean did i miss something did she
handle something outside of your former
home state of california emily where she
was a leader while you were a resident
there that i missed
i i really want to know that and and you
know
the other issue with kamala harris is
she doesn't even do a debrief on this
stuff she doesn't say let's hold a news
conference let me tell you why i went
there and then let me tell you what i
learned about border crisis and how i
might apply that like tapestry over the
crises here i mean look i can take a lot
of a learning curve i'm with pete
you want to be
bad at your job and and you know we can
all talk about that but what we want is
somebody who's trying to be better yeah
we want somebody who's trying to build
back better
rates on their own resume yeah
and so i i'm curious to know why she's
the person who becomes not our borders
are but europe's it's a great great
point and interestingly i think people
in the west wing are noticing how
ineffective she is carly the washington
post with this reporting one reflection
of the white house's struggles is the
low profile of vice president harris who
has little role
in the internal debates the current and
former officials said including two who
characterized her as quote completely
irrelevant these are biden officials
saying this yeah and hey um kayla you
hit the nail on the head when you said
focusing on the wrong things
there seems to be a really big
disconnect between the biden
administration and the american people
they're always going to have their
supporters of course but now you're
hearing about independents and even
democrats who are saying if this is what
big government looks like count me out
america was founded on the concept of
rejecting and restraining big government
so with that in mind how dare the
administration tell people to inject
their bodies with a vaccine that they
may not be comfortable with or tell moms
and dads
that they can't be involved in what
they're
with their children learner on the
billback better issue that usa today
poll found that 61
of people say that um it would either
hurt or have no effect on on their on
their families which is a total
rejection of the biden administration
being more involved in their everyday
lives and i think kamala harris
represents all of that and on top of
that she
seems to be very uncomfortable with the
role that she's been given oh but don't
worry she hired pr experts like
jinsaki's brother-in-law how's that
working out veep